progress has is never fair  and almost never just  and i feel i i think i my view of the  world is more like  how can we  give the soft landings to the  inevitable  destruction  that is ancillary to our  progress  and there it is  your jobs your livelihoods  are ancillary to our progress which  means uh insignificant right separated  from is there any more elitist phrase  that you've ever heard on a program so  right now we have a bunch of privileged  wealthy people game planning the entire  economy  under the guise of  climate justice while considering your  livelihood and everything they're in to  be ancillary there's no conspiracy that  my friends is the great reset